RYAN GERMICK: Hello there.
My name is Ryan and I lead
the Google Doodle team.
And I'm here with a very
special guest at the
Googleplex, Mr. Wayne White.
Give it up.
WAYNE WHITE: Thank you.
Thank you.
RYAN GERMICK: I'd been a fan of
Wayne's work before I even
knew there was such a thing
as being a fan.
His work entered into many
millions of American homes
with the puppet design and other
assorted creativity for
Pee Wee's Playhouse.
It was years later when I first
saw one of your word
paintings, the album cover for
Lambchop's "Nixon." And then a
few years later after that I was
in a diner in LA, Fred 62,
and I'm like, I know
this stuff.
And then a little bit longer
after that when I saw a
beautiful book that was recently
produced called "I
Will Now Get the--"
WAYNE WHITE: Maybe now.
RYAN GERMICK: Maybe now.
WAYNE WHITE: "Maybe Now I'll
Get the Respect I So Richly
Deserve."
RYAN GERMICK: Right.
WAYNE WHITE: Ey.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah.
I think today's the turning
point for that if I have
anything to do with it.
WAYNE WHITE: Finally.
RYAN GERMICK: Finally.
WAYNE WHITE: Today's the day.
RYAN GERMICK: September
10, 2012.
And it all came together in a
really wonderful movie that's
coming out this fall.
WAYNE WHITE: It's out now.
RYAN GERMICK: Technically out.
WAYNE WHITE: It premiered
September 7.
And it's called "Beauty Is
Embarrassing." And it's the
story of my life and times.
RYAN GERMICK: Wonderful.
And it's actually going to open
up in San Francisco and
many other Bay Area locations
this weekend.
WAYNE WHITE: Yes.
I will be in the Bay
Area this weekend.
It's going to be in San
Francisco, Berkeley, San Jose,
and Santa Cruz.
You can go to
beautyisembarrassing.com for
the theaters and times.
I can't remember them all.
But I take it a day at a time.
RYAN GERMICK: Like sevenish.
7 PM, maybe.
WAYNE WHITE: Yeah, probably.
7 or 8.
RYAN GERMICK: Evening time.
WAYNE WHITE: Yeah.
You can call the--
you can see the listings on
beautyisembarrassing.com and
call your theaters.
But I will be back up here.
I love the Bay Area.
Always have a great reception
when we come up here.
RYAN GERMICK: Pandering
to the local crowd.
WAYNE WHITE: I love you all.
[LAUGHTER]
RYAN GERMICK: And YouTube.
You love YouTube.
I imagine you love YouTube
and the people who
watch YouTube videos.
WAYNE WHITE: Of course.
Are you kidding?
I'm on YouTube every day.
RYAN GERMICK: Well, you have a
lot of new stuff going on.
Always moving forward.
If we could-- speaking
of moving forward.
But it's not--
you're not new to art.
This is actually--
this is a picture of your
great grandfather?
WAYNE WHITE: No.
It's me.
I've been doing these paintings
since 1878.
RYAN GERMICK: Ah.
You aged very well.
WAYNE WHITE: I am a vampire.
That's how I can do so much.
There's so much to talk about
just in this photograph.
One is that your eyes
look really weird.
Did you blink or something?
WAYNE WHITE: No.
Actually, this was
done by the great
photographer Stephen Berkman.
And this is his medium.
He uses an original 1860s
glass-plate negative camera.
It's called an ambrotype.
He plays by all the 19th
century rules.
Uses the same chemicals.
He uses only natural light.
And this particular kind of
film, the ambrotype, does not
pick up blue.
It does not pick
up light blues.
Blue reads as white.
So that's why my eyes
have that creepy
white glow to them.
Because I have light
blue eyes.
RYAN GERMICK: That's
a terrific answer.
Even if it's not true.
WAYNE WHITE: It's true.
It's true.
RYAN GERMICK: I believe you.
So I feel like we could talk for
the entire time just about
this image, because there's all
these other images in it.
But one thing I love, and I
think this kind of sums up in
many ways your philosophy.
I don't want you to spoil
all the good stuff.
But the "Hoozy Thinky
Iz" image.
Could you unpack that?
Who do think you are?
WAYNE WHITE: Yeah.
That particular painting there,
"Hoozy Thinky Iz," that
is sort of--
and I think a lot of my fellow
artists, maybe, can relate to
this, and I talk about
it in the movie--
it's a feeling of, especially
in our culture, who do you
think you are getting up
there and making a
spectacle of yourself?
You must have a very high
opinion of yourself to go out
there and push your so-called
"vision" on the world, or to
be an "artiste," as people
like to call you.
That's a subtle way of
putting you down.
I hate that word.
When so-- oh, here comes
the "artiste."
RYAN GERMICK: I use it just to
sort of make fun of the word.
WAYNE WHITE: Yeah.
Double back on it.
But this culture does not
respect or nurture artists.
Maybe the San Francisco area,
there's pockets of
culture that does.
But on the whole--
especially, you can understand,
being a Midwest
boy yourself.
I'm a Southern boy.
They do not respect and
nurture artists.
And you grow up with this sort
of insecure feeling of, yeah,
who do I think I am
for doing this?
Because everybody looks
askance at me.
And it takes a certain amount
of ego to be an artist.
And our culture also sort of
looks down on the ego, as they
should, because it can
get out of control.
But the artist ego is such that
you start to question it.
Well, maybe I am a little out
of control with the ego.
And who do I think I am?
And it's just the natural
insecurity of the human
condition to question
yourself that way.
And it's amplified when you
take the artist's path.
And it's amplified also
when you see people
better than you are.
Well, who do I think I am?
This guy's ten times
better than me.
I'm humbled by it.
RYAN GERMICK: You mentioned
respect for artists.
That's a good lead-in to-- we
have another slide, if you
want to show.
Talk a little bit about
this painting.
WAYNE WHITE: This is called
"Picasso's Ass Falling Off."
Now, this is a secret that I've
never revealed when I've
said this title or showed
this painting.
I first heard the expression
"ass falling off" from the
artist James Rosenquist.
RYAN GERMICK: Oh, yeah.
He used to be a billboard
painter.
Another commercial artist
turned fine artist.
WAYNE WHITE: Yes.
He's a very famous pop artist.
Very influential
in the culture.
And I happened to meet him at
a party once that I went to
with the great Red Grooms, who
I also worked for at one time
in New York City.
And I was like this 24-year-old
kid straight out
of Tennessee in this room full
of these superstars of
American art.
And Rosenquist was holding
court about his days as a
billboard painter.
This is kind of off topic, but--
he goes, yeah, and I
went to the boss that day.
I said, boss, I feel like my
ass is going to fall off.
And I thought about that
term for years.
And I associated it with
art and artists.
And that inspired me to have
Picasso's ass falling off.
And this is just sort
of a jab at the king
of art, Pablo Picasso.
I mean, that's a guy that
anybody who's put pencil to
paper or tried to make a
painting, that's one guy you
have to get around or
over or through.
You have to pass through Picasso
Land sooner or later
if you're an artist.
And this is just kind of like
throwing darts at the king.
I love Picasso.
All artists do.
You can't help but.
You have to pay respect.
But at the same time, this
reflects one of my abiding
passions in art, is to bring
humor into fine art.
And to poke pins in
pretensions, to
rail against the king.
That's a very American thing.
We hate kings.
That's why this culture--
that's why
this country was started.
To rail against monarchy.
To break down class systems.
And that's a big part of
what humor does, is
to break down walls.
And to laugh at class
distinctions and everything.
And to bring everything to
a level playing field.
We're all hairless apes.
RYAN GERMICK: Well, some
more than others.
So what is it about art
that is so afraid of
humor, do you think?
Is that universal, or do you
think it's historical?
WAYNE WHITE: It's not
necessarily universal.
First of all, I consider humor
an elevated form of
consciousness.
I think it's one of the most
sacred, valuable qualities we
have as human beings.
And so why shouldn't it be
worthy of the canon of art?
Why shouldn't it be in
museums and whatnot?
I consider stand-up comics,
especially people like Richard
Pryor, Lenny Bruce, George
Carlin to be fine artists.
It's one of the finest
art forms there is.
But you know, art is
famously humorless.
Especially critics, curators.
A certain type of class
consciousness invades art.
People go to the best schools,
Ivy League schools.
Ivy League people control the
art world through criticism
and through curatorship.
And through the fast track that
they're on by going to
these moneyed schools.
Moneyed schools do not want
to talk about humor.
Humor is considered lightweight
and low.
It's considered an
entertainment.
And not worthy of serious
contemplation.
RYAN GERMICK: Did you ever
read the book "Ways of
Seeing," by John Berger?
WAYNE WHITE: Yes.
I've read all--
that's another thing.
RYAN GERMICK: You've
read every book?
WAYNE WHITE: I've read
every book there is.
No, I--
RYAN GERMICK: Makes it easier
to discuss with
you, because I--
WAYNE WHITE: I come from
this working class,
chip-on-my-shoulder kind
of attitude, but
I've run the gamut.
I've read Berger, Clement
Greenberg, all the criticisms.
I love fine art.
I love the higher
forms of art.
I love seriousness.
I love drama.
I love the challenges
of difficult art.
I'm not discounting any of it,
I'm just saying there's room
for other forms of it.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah.
Well, the thing that
blew my mind.
I was in high school, I think,
when an art teacher gave that
book to me.
And this is less about humor
but more about the value of
maybe commercial art, was he--
and I totally maybe misread
this, so someone could go back
and look this up, and this was
like 15, 16 years ago.
But I remember him talking about
fine art having this
inherent classicism because it's
an art object owned by
one person.
And with that rarity and
scarcity, it becomes a
situation of supply and demand
and the rich person gets it.
And so I think it's
interesting--
you've had multi-faceted career
we talked about it a
little bit.
But art that is not exclusive to
one person but can still be
art seems to threaten that
long-established supply and demand.
WAYNE WHITE: And Berger, if
I'm not mistaken was a
communist , or at least
a socialist.
He was.
RYAN GERMICK: There seemed
to be implications, yeah.
WAYNE WHITE: He was a
radical socialist.
And he believed in bringing up
the thorny problem of class
within the art world.
And that's a dirty secret of
the art world, is it's very
much ruled by money.
And the moneyed class.
And I forgot my direction.
RYAN GERMICK: Can I tell you
a story why I chose in art
school not to go into fine
art but to go into
illustration as a major?
WAYNE WHITE: Sure.
Please do.
RYAN GERMICK: So I was in--
I feel like I should be
looking at the camera.
This is a serious moment.
I was 18 years old.
I went to Parsons School
of Design.
And the fine arts department
has wonderful
students and teachers.
But when I went to the
information session, when
they're trying to get you to
pick a major, they had free
pizza, which was a
big draw for me.
Poor student and whatnot.
And they were going on and on
about how wonderful their
facilities were.
That they had state of the art--
they had studio space
right in Manhattan and access to
the galleries and museums.
And for people that were into
sculpture, they had just
bought a plasma cutter.
And meanwhile, I'm trying to
get pizza off of the pie.
I'm trying to pull this slice of
pizza and kind of trying to
keep it cool, but the smart alec
in me couldn't help but
blurt out, could I
use the plasma
cutter to get this pizza?
WAYNE WHITE: And that went
over like a led balloon?
RYAN GERMICK: Totally
crickets.
And then I was like, I don't
need these guys.
WAYNE WHITE: Yeah.
There you go.
I know.
It's like, humor is one of my
acid tests for human beings.
You know what I mean?
If somebody doesn't have a sense
of humor, it's over.
I can't relate to them.
I value humor.
And paradoxically, you can't
analyze humor and put it on
too high an elevation
or it kills it.
It's this precious little flower
that has to grow in a
certain way, but why can't
it grow in a museum?
Why can't it be considered
worthy of--
I think it has depth.
I do.
As much depth as any
other form of art.
RYAN GERMICK: I agree
with you.
WAYNE WHITE: The best humor has
levels of sadness and all
the emotions.
RYAN GERMICK: Right on.
Can I get the next slide?
So this is somewhat of a
good transition here.
So you grew up in Tennessee,
as you mentioned.
WAYNE WHITE: Yes.
Chattanooga, Tennessee.
RYAN GERMICK: Chattanooga.
And then you moved
to New York.
Kind of high-tailed--
you went to college
in Tennessee.
WAYNE WHITE: I had four years
of undergraduate school at a
state university, Middle
Tennessee State University.
I drifted around Nashville,
Tennessee for a half year
after I graduated.
I saw a magazine called "Raw
Magazine" put out by Art
Spiegelman in 1981.
And that inspired me to move to
New York, because I saw in
that magazine, and his spirit,
and the artists in that
magazine, the birth of a
new world, the birth
of a new art form.
And I was right.
That magazine and that scene in
the early '80s in New York
is becoming true today in the
Renaissance of graphic novels.
Go to any comic book store.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah,
it's everywhere.
WAYNE WHITE: And it all started
back then, at least in
America, in the early '80s in
New York City down on Greene
Street in Soho in Art
Spiegelman's studio.
RYAN GERMICK: When you were in
Middle Tennessee University,
you also found a community
of folks.
WAYNE WHITE: I was lucky enough,
coincidentally, to run
into fellow weirdo oddballs from
small towns of the South.
And we were all dying to
validate each other.
We had all come from a
suppressed background.
We had all been made to
feel like outsiders.
And suddenly, we were together
and reinforcing each other.
And I always say, your fellow
students are just as
important, or maybe more
important, to your education
than your teachers are.
I think you can learn as much
from your peers as you can
from your instructors and your
so-called authority figures.
And that's where I first came
out of my shell and first
learned about art
and art history.
And just as art as a lifestyle,
as something that
can bleed out of the classroom,
into the streets,
become a part of your
everyday life.
RYAN GERMICK: So it seems
clear to me--
and I had a similar experience
when I went to--
feel free to check your
email or whatever.
We can cut this out.
So it seems clear to me that
that community helped as a
launching pad.
And I'm sure many of the
creative people in the
audience and watching this on
YouTube or whatever have had
that experience.
Do you feel like now in today's
very connected world--
how do you feel technology is
helping people find weirdos
and communities that they feel
accepted and validated by?
WAYNE WHITE: I think
it's helping a lot.
I think it's helping connect
people in ways
that are really positive.
I'm not one of those guys that
rues the day before computers.
believes in a golden age or
the good old days.
Young people, please, believe
this for sure.
There's no good old days.
There's no golden age that
you missed out on.
You're not missing
out on anything.
You're alive right now.
Now's your golden age.
Don't listen to some old fart
tell you it used to be better.
Because it wasn't.
It wasn't better.
What is important is, make
this your golden age.
And when you get to be my age,
don't sit around saying, boy,
back in the Google days, back
when Google first started--
don't do that.
Please, remember this day
when I'm telling you.
Don't turn into one
of those people.
Look forward.
Keep believing in the future.
And change.
RYAN GERMICK: Next.
So I want to go a
little bit back.
This is a still from
the movie.
It's one of my favorite
sections.
There's a lot of talk in the
movie about your upbringing.
And about your relationship with
both your family, like
your parents, but then your new
family, which is really
terrific, which we'll talk
about in a second.
But it just goes over--
you have a line in the
movie that I love.
And this is your sister
about to spank you.
WAYNE WHITE: Yes.
RYAN GERMICK: And you said
something like your sister was
the person who told you you were
going to die one day and
made sure you understood
the concept.
WAYNE WHITE: Yes.
RYAN GERMICK: I love
that because--
WAYNE WHITE: That's what I'm--
that's what the V.O. is right
when this scene is happening.
I said, and my sister was
the first bad-ass.
She was the one that told me I
was going to die one day and
made sure I was crystal
clear on the concept.
RYAN GERMICK: So we chatted
a little bit earlier and--
WAYNE WHITE: And it's true.
RYAN GERMICK: --you were talking
about the old fogies
talking about the good old days,
and how that relates to
a fear of death.
WAYNE WHITE: Yeah.
RYAN GERMICK: In a sense.
I'm kind of curious how-- if you
would unpack that for me.
And also, your sister-- you're
just a youngin here.
WAYNE WHITE: Yeah, I'm like
four years old there.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah, and she's
letting-- you know, I'm
imagining at an early age,
this idea of you're an
infallible mortal is a pretty
heavy thing to learn.
But it seems like you take that
lesson to heart today.
WAYNE WHITE: You know what, I
can trace my first existential
crisis to that day when my
sister very patiently
explained to me that we
were all going to be
dead forever one day.
And I remember the feeling when
it first pierced me, that
that was a realization.
And I've had anxiety attacks
my whole life about that.
And I think a lot of us have
the same feelings.
I think a lot of us, the
mortality thing creeps up on
you when you least expect it,
and you are short of breath.
And you suddenly realize, wow,
this is a limited engagement
we're all in.
And I think that's a painful
realization, but I think it's
a realization that most
artists share.
That's one of the motivators,
that's one of the engines of
art, is knowing that
this is a limited
engagement, that we're here.
Time is precious.
And we've got to do the
best we can with it.
I think that one of the great
things about artists, is they
take advantage of that time.
I think we all have this acute
realization that we're mortal.
And I think art is sort
of, as they say--
the academic term
is memento mori.
That's one of the big
themes of art.
It's been there ever
since art began.
Still lives from the
golden age--
here I go, golden age.
Still lives--
RYAN GERMICK: Well, as a
vampire, you have a much wider
perspective.
WAYNE WHITE: Still lives from
the Renaissance on are
symbolic of death.
They're called memento mori.
Fruit, flowers--
those are subtle symbols of
death, and reminding us of the
mortal coil.
So the realization of mortality
is built into art.
And that's what gives it its
poignancy and power.
And that's what gives
humor its power.
Humor is often a reaction
against a--
RYAN GERMICK: Release
against fear.
WAYNE WHITE: --a release
Facing that horrible truth.
So that's why humor should be
right up there, along with the
old masters and stuff.
Because that's what
an artist does.
He defies death, yet he also
comes to terms with it.
And that's why art is in
the spiritual realm.
RYAN GERMICK: Do you want to--
I come from a big family.
I'm the middle of five kids.
And I know that my siblings
did a lot to
shape me as a person.
And as a creative person.
What about you?
From what I gather, it doesn't
seem like your sister was
particularly creative, but your
mom was pretty creative.
WAYNE WHITE: My mother was
the first artist, so to
speak, in my life.
The first aesthete.
Mind you, I grew
up in a very--
it was the '60s in the South,
which was the '50s, really.
RYAN GERMICK: But it's
still 10 years above
the Midwest, I think.
It's still like the
future for us.
WAYNE WHITE: Yeah, I mean, I
grew up in a blue collar
environment.
All my father's friends, my
father himself, they all work
at DuPont nylon factory.
There wasn't an artist
in sight.
There wasn't a gallery
There wasn't a museum.
And so the first artist in that
kind of environment was
my mother, because she
loved antiques.
She loved to decorate.
She took me to antique
stores all the time.
She admired objects
for their beauty.
And her sense of interior
decorating--
she redecorated the house
like every month.
So she was a designer.
And she was my first idea of
someone who could enjoy the
visual, and enjoy expressing
the visual.
RYAN GERMICK: Wanna hit
the next slide?
So this a shot of
your family now.
Or from the movie.
A couple years back, I guess.
And everybody seems
really creative.
What's it like being almost
inverted in a sense, where now
you're in a family
full of artists?
Your wife, Mimi Pond--
WAYNE WHITE: Yes, that's my
wife, Mimi Pond, my daughter
Lulu White, and my son, Woodrow
White, who is an art
major here in Oakland
at the California
College of the Arts.
And of course, my wife is
a famous cartoonist.
A lot of you are familiar
with her work.
She's been on the national scene
since the late '70s.
She started out here in Oakland
at the California
College the Arts.
RYAN GERMICK: She wrote the
first episode of "The
Simpsons."
WAYNE WHITE: She wrote the
first episode of "The
Simpsons." She started out in
the "National Lampoon" back
when it was a good magazine.
Back when it was the "National
Lampoon" in the late '70s.
She went on to create the
Valley Girls craze.
She wrote the best-selling book
"Valley Girls' Guide to
Life." She's done five
other humor books.
She's working on a 500-page opus
about her life in Oakland
in the '70s, when punks took
over from the hippies.
And my daughter is a very
talented painter.
And it just came to
them naturally.
It's in the genes.
And this is my dream come true,
to nurture artists and
be surrounded by artists in my
own little bubble there in Los
Feliz, in Los Angeles,
California.
RYAN GERMICK: Cool.
So I think next--
this is a trailer
from the movie.
I thought we'd just play it.
Just to give people an idea.
WAYNE WHITE: This is "Beauty
Is Embarrassing."
WAYNE WHITE: Thank you.
RYAN GERMICK: I watched
it twice last week.
I didn't have to, and I
liked it that much.
WAYNE WHITE: And you're
still talking to me.
RYAN GERMICK: Oh, yeah.
I'd watch it again.
WAYNE WHITE: You heard him.
RYAN GERMICK: It's good stuff.
I mean, there was so much
packed in there.
And you guys should definitely
see the movie.
Happy to shill for you,
it was a great movie.
One is that you play banjo,
which you didn't bring.
WAYNE WHITE: No.
CROWD: Aww.
WAYNE WHITE: Sorry.
RYAN GERMICK: Two is that you
dance, which you don't need
any banjo for.
WAYNE WHITE: No.
They say-- you know
that phrase "dance
like nobody's watching"?
I forgot that people
were watching.
RYAN GERMICK: Well, the
third is that--
I want to talk a bit
about "Pee Wee."
WAYNE WHITE: Sure.
RYAN GERMICK: So "Pee
Wee" was a special
thing in American culture.
WAYNE WHITE: It sure was.
RYAN GERMICK: It was just
so much creativity and
originality.
And it was a huge hit.
WAYNE WHITE: Yeah.
RYAN GERMICK: I mean, it was
a big deal in my childhood.
And just basically, as a weird
kid in the Midwest, it felt
like a breath of fresh air.
And I think Matt Groening said
it best, when he said--he was
referring to "Pee Wee" in the
trailer when he said, if this
could make it, there's
hope for us all.
WAYNE WHITE: Yes.
RYAN GERMICK: And that's what
I took away from the movie,
but in particular from "Pee
Wee." That's just one of these
moments of, you know,
the good guys won.
WAYNE WHITE: Yeah.
RYAN GERMICK: How did you
go from your New York
cartooning into that?
And I just want to hear
all about it.
WAYNE WHITE: Well, like I said,
I moved to New York to
be a cartoonist.
But at the same time, I'd been
doing these crazy, wacky
puppet shows on my own.
Just these do-it-yourself
homemade productions.
I started those back in
Tennessee at the university.
When punk rock first hit, I
couldn't play a guitar, so I
picked up a puppet instead.
And I did these things,
I called them
punk rock puppet shows.
The first one was called "Punk
and Juicy." And the puppets
bled fountains of blood.
We would throw bowls
of Cheerios
and milk at the audience.
We'd set fire to the stage.
We'd come out and choke members
of the audience and
provoke fights.
It was very confrontational.
It was kind of anti-puppet.
It was the era of Andy Kaufman
and Mr. Bill and, like
I said, punk rock.
It was all about deconstruction
and
destruction, you know?
It was about kicking down the
old conventions and finding
something new, taking apart
the idea of show business,
confronting the audience.
Which is not a new
idea at all.
It was also my idea
of art history.
I thought of myself as a Dadaist
in the tradition of
Hugo Ball and all those guys
that came out of the aftermath
of World War I.
RYAN GERMICK: Sounds like the
perfect set for children's
television.
WAYNE WHITE: Perfect.
Right up kids' alley.
Everybody wants to know about a
dystopian future, you know?
RYAN GERMICK: Right.
Right.
What was that transition?
Who was the visionary that
pulled all of you crazies in?
WAYNE WHITE: Well, I kept
doing those puppet
shows on the side.
And everybody thought I
was crazy to do it.
And lo and behold, that puppet
show experience got me the job
on "Pee Wee's Playhouse."
And that's another lesson I
impart to young artists, or
people who want to
be an artist.
Everybody thought I was
nuts to do that, to do
those puppet shows.
They kept trying to give me all
this common sense advice--
Wayne, focus.
Be a graphic artist.
Be an Illustrator.
Go where the money is.
Use your sense.
Quit playing with dolls
all the time.
But lo and behold, what
everybody thought was a crazy
waste of time led to the most
money I ever made and led to
the best career I ever had.
That crazy, playing with doll
impulse led me to a house in
Los Angeles and raising
two kids.
So don't discount your secret
love that you might be a
little bit embarrassed
or ashamed to do.
I mean, that's part of--
the title of the
movie comes from that.
Often, what we love is
a guilty pleasure.
Or we're afraid to expose our
true, vulnerable self through
the things we love.
And we're embarrassed, often, by
the things we love, or the
things we really want to do.
But truth is beauty.
And beauty is embarrassing.
Don't be embarrassed by it.
It's kind of like giving you
permission to wear your heart
on your sleeve.
And this culture does not want
you to wear your heart on your
sleeve, especially when
you're young.
The prototype for the young is,
be wised up and cynical
and world-weary.
RYAN GERMICK: What's
up with that--
WAYNE WHITE: Don't go around so
wide-eyed, you're going to
get the crap knocked out
of you, you know?
Build that shell and keep
building layers on that shell.
Wise up.
RYAN GERMICK: So like with the
kind of hipster mentality is
sort of like a very
self-serious--
kind of the opposite
of punk, in a way.
WAYNE WHITE: The hipster
mentality is mostly full of
crap, because they don't
respect the wide-eyed
enthusiasm of the artist.
You're supposed to be all
world-weary and depressed.
And that's supposed to be
a cool thing to do.
Well, I've been depressed.
There's nothing cool about
being depressed.
True depression is a
shameful way to be.
And it's anti-life.
But back to your question, who
pulled it all together?
Paul Reubens pulled
it all together.
Paul Reubens was our champion.
He had just come off the movie
"Pee Wee's Big Adventure," Tim
Burton's first feature.
And he was hot as a pistol.
And he had the power that
celebrity can give you.
And also, he was the rare
combination of a celebrity who
totally understood art and
the creative spirit.
And he championed us.
He protected us from
the network.
And also, a woman named Judy
Price, who was in charge of
children's programming,
had the same rebel
spirit that he did.
And they both protected
us from the network.
Usually, networks kill
everything with their notes
and their meddling and their
worrying about making money
and whatnot.
But we were in our own
protective bubble.
And that's the power
of the show.
It was a downtown New York art
project done by people all new
to Hollywood, a bunch of
underground cartoonists,
painters, and sculptors.
And it just happened to be a New
York art project that got
on national television.
And that's exactly its power.
RYAN GERMICK: Awesome.
Next slide.
WAYNE WHITE: And, of
course, the genius
of the Pee Wee character.
I mean, what a great
character.
He deserves to be right up there
with Buster Keaton and
all the greats.
RYAN GERMICK: So we have a
couple slides of your drawings
from the time.
Talk about-- where did
Randy come from?
WAYNE WHITE: Well, Randy-- all
the characters were already on
paper when I came along.
I didn't invent the concepts,
but I did invent the visuals.
And Randy, of course, is a
classic redheaded bully.
I was bullied by a redhead
in school.
And I originally wanted (IN
SOUTHERN ACCENT) Randy to have
a southern accent.
But no, they wanted to go with
this classic, (DOING CHARACTER
VOICE) yeah, kind of Bowery
boys kind of thing.
So I went with that.
RYAN GERMICK: You were
also the voice--
WAYNE WHITE: I was the-- (DOING
CHARACTER VOICE) yeah,
I was the voice.
Yeah, smoking's cool,
boys and girls.
And he's the classic bully that
we've all confronted.
I mean, one of the classic
redheaded bullies in cinema is
the kid from "A Christmas
Story." But I
wasn't thinking of him.
I was thinking of my own
personal experience.
But I was delighted to see that
particular redheaded bully.
That's another cultural
icon, that kid.
RYAN GERMICK: What is it about
redheads that makes them such
bad people?
WAYNE WHITE: Well, are there
any gingers here today?
RYAN GERMICK: I'm
just kidding.
WAYNE WHITE: I don't know.
It's just-- red.
You know, seeing red.
Red is the flag of danger.
Plus, they have freckles.
And freckles on a puppet
are always fun to do.
RYAN GERMICK: We look forward
to the comments on
the video from that.
WAYNE WHITE: And Randy also
represents the return to a
classic puppet look that we
wanted to bring to "Pee Wee's
Playhouse."
RYAN GERMICK: It looks--
Howdy Doody seems like
a reference there.
WAYNE WHITE: Howdy Doody,
the great Peter
Baird, the Jerry Mahoney--
hard surfaces on puppets.
The Muppets had ruled the roost
for so long with that
plush toy, felt, and ping-pong
ball aesthetic that everybody
and their brother had copied.
I love the Muppets.
Jim Henson was a great genius.
But man, they had cornered
the market on puppets.
And we wanted to bring back a
more classic puppet look.
And Randy was a classic
example of that.
RYAN GERMICK: Another
character you
worked on was Mr. Kite.
WAYNE WHITE: Yes. (DOING VOICE)
Yes, and I was also the
voice of Mr. Kite.
Rain, Pee Wee, rain.
And of course, at the time, I
was so ambitious and eager, I
worked harder--
That's another quality
of mine.
I was a horrible student.
I didn't listen to
the teacher.
I cased the room.
OK, who's the best
one in here?
OK, I'm going to beat you.
It was always a competition
with me in a classroom.
I wanted to be the best.
And I wanted to figure out how
to beat everybody else.
That's what my sports background
has taught me.
Maybe a little too
competitive.
And in that spirit of
competition, I did like 50
pages of drawings
of Mr. Kites.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah,
I wondered--
I saw the numbers.
It's like 454.
Are those really sequential?
WAYNE WHITE: I would go
overboard with the drawing and
the ideas, making sure that I
was running circles around
everybody in the room.
I might not have been the best
drawer or the most talent, but
I was damn sure going to
be the hardest worker.
And so I drew the
hell out of--
and it wound up being the
simplest thing possible, of
course, after all my ideas.
And so this is a good example
of the design process.
But it's also a good example of
my over-reaching attitude.
And my overworking attitude.
Which is a good thing to have.
I mean, that's another thing.
If you're not the most talented
in the room, make
sure you're the hardest
working in the room.
It'll get you somewhere.
RYAN GERMICK: Next over there is
a clip from the movie, that
I kind of cut up about "Pee
Wee." Let's check it out.
That was great.
RYAN GERMICK: I would
like that DVD.
Of the Pee Wee Herman that no
one ever saw. "Pee Wee" show.
WAYNE WHITE: Well, hopefully
it's going to be on the extras
on the DVD that comes
out in February.
For the movie.
RYAN GERMICK: Awesome.
So this is one of the
word paintings.
So to summarize, I guess, you
had a really successful run in
Hollywood with "Pee Wee" and
"Beakman's World" and a bunch
of other shows.
And then you kind
of burnt out.
Fair to say?
WAYNE WHITE: Yes.
The typical Hollywood story.
I was overworked.
I was over-saturated with doing
kid shows and puppets.
I was typed as the wacky
kid show guy.
And I just needed a
break from it all.
That's where my depression
came in.
I was exhausted physically.
And, like I said, that thing
about working harder than
anybody in the room, it
has its liabilities.
And I literally worked
myself into a rut.
Into a hole.
And I had to get out
of that hole.
And so I thought I would
return to painting.
But I wanted to do a 180 from
this cartoon expressionism.
And I wanted to not return to
the abstract expressionism I
was taught in undergraduate
school.
So I taught myself traditional
painting techniques.
I started looking at Winslow
Homer and Thomas Eakins and
the Hudson River
Valley school.
I bought a book about
how to paint
traditional oil paintings.
And I started doing these
history paintings.
Again, hearkening back to my
Chattanooga childhood--
the Civil War, the
Cherokee Indians.
The scenic beauty
of the place.
And I was doing these very
traditional kind of history
paintings with kind of
weird psychological
undertones to them.
And I was buying thrift store
paintings just for the frames.
And the paintings started
getting a little more surreal,
but they were still
traditionally painted.
And I thought one day,
I'm going to put
words into the painting.
Into a landscape.
And I picked out one
of the thrift store
landscapes for the frame.
And right before I kicked the
cheap reproduction out, I
thought, what about if I just
painted on the landscape that
was already in there.
It would save a lot of time.
And so on a moment's whim,
sponta-- spontane--
I can't say words today.
Spontaneously, I painted the
words into the already
pre-existing cheap landscape
reproduction.
And thus was born a series that
I call "word paintings."
And maybe that's how you
first knew of me.
That's certainly my most
notorious body of work.
And it's how I got into
the fine arts world.
I'm still painting them today.
RYAN GERMICK: I want to just
give you a shout-out, because
there's some really beautiful
technical stuff going on with
the paintings.
The lighting on the letters and
the ripples in the water.
It's really well done.
WAYNE WHITE: Thank you.
That was from the years of
self-study of oil painting
techniques.
And doing traditional type
of rendering it in paint.
These are in acrylic,
but acrylic is
just fake oil paint.
And I only use landscape
reproductions.
I don't paint on originals.
Originals have too much of
a human smell on them.
Plus, that would be an act of
defacement, because then that
original is gone forever.
These reproductions are just
empty commodities.
There's thousands, maybe even
millions, of these things.
And they're like
an empty stage.
There's no real art there.
There's no human presence.
But they are a beautiful setting
for these words.
And I don't think of
them as defacement.
I think of them as collaboration
with the artist.
Because I respect his color
palette, his sense of light.
The environmental--
I try to get the shadows and
everything just right.
So it's a bit of a collaboration
with these
long-dead masters of this
sofa art genre.
And of course, I discovered--
what began as just a jokey
gesture deepened as I started
to look at it.
It references so many things--
Americana, the sense
of the past.
It's using these objects that
everybody can relate to.
They've all seen these paintings
at granny's house or
in their own house.
Or at the dentist's office.
They're a ubiquitous part of
American culture, these
prevalent, kitschy things.
So there's that reference
point.
There's art history
references.
And of course, there's the layer
of humor I bring to it.
So they were very resonant in a
way that I never planned in
a million years.
And I think a lot of the
best discoveries and
ideas happen that way.
They just kind of bubble up
from your subconscious.
And you can't pre-plan art.
It's being in the moment.
The creative act is not
an act of analysis.
It's just listening to some
weird gut-- or some weird
voice inside of yourself.
And these are a testament
to that.
RYAN GERMICK: I think we have
a couple more to check out.
WAYNE WHITE: Yes.
This one's called "Just a
Picture/ Shunned by Scholars/
Now it Costs $10,000." And
that's my tribute to the old
Burma-Shave signs.
I'm sure a lot of you don't--
ever heard of that.
But people of a certain age--
I'm a little too young, even.
But in the early '50s, there was
a series of advertisements
by the side of the road,
rhyming signs--
like every 50 yards would to
be a sign and they rhymed.
And then the payoff would
be, Burma Shave!
It was a nice little piece
of sequential art by
the side of the road.
And I always loved that.
And we had our own versions of
it down in Chattanooga with
tourist traps, especially the
Georgia Game Park. "See
three-headed dog." "See
blah blah blah."
But it didn't rhyme.
This is a direct reference to
the Burma Shave campaigns.
And I'm a big fan of roadside
attractions and Americana.
And early motels and
advertising.
And anything that has to do with
roadside America, I love.
And it's, of course, a sly
dig at the pretensions of
high and low art.
I don't know if it's
sly or not.
RYAN GERMICK: This one--
WAYNE WHITE: This is a series
of works I did where I would
pour paint on the picture, let
it puddle and dry, and then I
would look at it.
Then I would tell you
what it looks like.
To me, that looked like the
profile of Norman Rockwell.
RYAN GERMICK: I can see that.
The long neck, kind of
like turtle head.
WAYNE WHITE: Yeah.
You know, we've all seen those
pictures of him leaning over
with a pipe in his
mouth painting.
See the nose and the
big cranium.
And I did five or
six of those.
Didn't sell a one.
Nobody liked these.
I love them.
Again, it's commenting on the
pretensions of art and how
people really look at art.
None of us--
come on, admit it.
You look at an abstract painting
and after a while,
you start going, hey, that
looks like a dog.
And it's about cloud gazing.
We all love to find shapes.
We all love to impose our
meaning on the world, a world
that's really scientifically
chaotic, indifferent, and
couldn't care if we
lived or died.
Yet, we want to impose our human
qualities on that world.
We're constantly trying to find
narrative and meaning in
accidents and chaos
and in nature.
And that's what that's
reflective on, both our
instinctive view of
the world and the
pretensions of high art.
And it's funny, I think.
WAYNE WHITE: Yes. "The Most
Expensive Painting in the
World." Hyperbole is funny.
That painting, too,
is about that big.
RYAN GERMICK: It should
be encased behind
like six inches of--
WAYNE WHITE: Yes, like
the Mona Lisa.
RYAN GERMICK: --bullet-proof
glass.
WAYNE WHITE: Absolutely.
So that's, again, just
a pot shot at the
pretensions of the world.
The insane economy of art.
The insane way things
accrue value.
You know.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah.
I mean, back to my
plasma-cutting pizza
experience.
It also became clear to me
pretty early on living in New
York as a Midwestern teenager
that the gallery art system is
no less ridiculous than
shlubbing to the Village Voice
to drop off your editorial
illustration portfolio.
WAYNE WHITE: Yes.
And again, it's all
about being--
the art world is fashion.
And we all know how
absurd fashion is.
I mean, if you look to "The
New York Times" fashion
supplement magazine, it's
the most ridiculous
thing in the world.
Who wears those fashions?
Nobody does.
I don't understand fashion.
These men strutting down the
catwalk wearing, like, Speedos
with a fur jacket.
And they're taking
it seriously.
It's all done with
a straight face.
And it's so offensive to human
nature, fashion is.
I have another painting, it's
called "Good-looking People
Having Fun Without You." That's
the number one message
of the media.
That's the number one message
Look what you missed.
Look what you are missing
out on, loser.
You better buy this watch or
these shoes or this jacket to
get in on the party that
you're missing out on.
And you never find that
party your whole life.
Even the people at the party
aren't at that party.
There's this mythic,
unattainable, super sexy,
super cool ideal that capitalist
culture creates and
drives us forward by our nose.
And it's bullshit.
And we live our lives with this
insecurity because of that.
And I think that's a sacred
mission, is to knock down
those false idols.
The emperor's new clothes
kind of thing.
To break through that and unite
us in the fact that
we're all just these vulnerable
creatures.
And that's just crap just to get
you to spend your money.
RYAN GERMICK: I am with you.
But I saw the show that was at
the San Francisco de Young
Museum recently for Jean
Paul Gaultier.
That guy's pretty on point.
WAYNE WHITE: Well, you know what
There's geniuses in the
fashion world.
Again, I take these polemical
points and it sounds--
I do that for the rhetoric
and the passion.
And to reach out on an
emotional level.
But everything is super
complicated.
I can't hit on all the points.
I just have rhetoric.
But fashion is an ingenious,
fascinating visual form.
And there's elegance
and beauty to it.
RYAN GERMICK: And even
humor sometimes.
WAYNE WHITE: And humor.
There's everything there.
RYAN GERMICK: But most of the
time it's pretty ridiculous.
WAYNE WHITE: But it's really in
the hands of money makers.
I'm not belittling any fashion
designer or anybody who's
interested in it, but it gets
in the hands of the money
makers and they ruin it.
Money makers always
ruin everything.
But we all gotta
make money too.
Again, another, like--
you can't take any position in
this world without it having a
direct opposite.
I'm finding that out as I go
around and become more of a
public speaker.
I'm often caught up in the heat
of my rhetoric, and I'm
thinking, you know, somebody
could debate me down to the
ground on this.
But I'm trying to hit these
emotional points that we all
can relate to.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah.
What do we got-- what's
our next one?
So it looks like--
WAYNE WHITE: It got crazy.
RYAN GERMICK: It got crazy.
WAYNE WHITE: Yeah.
I got tired of the straight
ahead text.
I simply wanted to do
variations, and see how far I
could push it.
These are words made out of
a cartoon Western town.
You know, why not?
And it literally says, "all
an act." There's an A
laying on its side.
There's an L, another L, an A,
the C reaching up into the
buggy, and then the last T.
And I was literally trying to
push the idea of typography as
far as I could go.
And take the street, a Western
cartoon-like tourist town
street that you'd see, you
know, in a comic book.
And use those as the post and
lintels of typography.
RYAN GERMICK: Yeah.
Cool.
So I just keep trying to
push the limits and the
possibilities of typography.
I think typography is
a great art form.
And worthy of--
I'm sure a lot of you--
of course, Google is
built on the--
a lot of the Google image
is about typography.
It's an incredible topic,
inexhaustible.
RYAN GERMICK: This is now
actually a physical object.
WAYNE WHITE: It's an
aluminum cut-out.
Laser-cut aluminum that
floats about two
inches from the wall.
It says, "let's have a smirking
contest." That's
another condition of society.
You were talking about earlier
with hipsters.
It seems like the default
position of our
society is the smirk.
If you're smirking,
you're cool, man.
You're ready for all comers.
You got your guard up.
Everything's bullshit.
I'm going to smirk
about everything.
I'm cool.
I'm too cool to believe
in anything.
Nihilism seems to be the
default position of our
society in so many ways.
And the intellectual challenges
seem to be who can
be the smirkiest.
Or who can be the most
disbelieving.
Who can cut each
other the most.
It's a cruel world.
And why?
Why?
But it's also funny too. "Let's
have a smirk--" that
seems to boil it all down.
When two hipsters meet, it's
a smirking contest.
But on a technical, visual
level, this reflects my love
of sculpture and objecthood.
And literally taking the words
out of the context and making
them a sculptural object.
And I love painted metal.
This is like painted aluminum.
Acrylic on aluminum.
RYAN GERMICK: So I
think we have--
next is one more clip, where it
kind of brings it home back
to Tennessee with one of
your good friends--
so we'll watch this--
and a project that
you did with him.
[APPLAUSE]
WAYNE WHITE: Thank you.
RYAN GERMICK: Well, I just want
to thank you so much for
bringing so many of your
ideas to life.
And letting them come alive and
sharing with them with us
and sharing them
with the world.
WAYNE WHITE: My pleasure.
It's great to be
here at Google.
RYAN GERMICK: It's been
great to talk to you.
And if anybody has questions,
there's a mic in the center.
And you can ask Wayne whatever's
on your mind.
WAYNE WHITE: Come on up.
Please.
Make me look good.
RYAN GERMICK: What do you got?
What do you got?
WAYNE WHITE: No?
RYAN GERMICK: Can't tell if
they're leaving or if they're
going to come up.
Oh, here we go.
JULIE: Hi.
I'm Julie.
WAYNE WHITE: Hi, Julie.
JULIE: And I want to know, how
did Neil find you or decide to
make a documentary about you?
WAYNE WHITE: Well, I met Neil
12 years ago, when he was a
young punk right out
of Oklahoma.
He was an unpaid intern at this
design company where I
was working.
And I paid no attention
to him at all.
I just thought, please,
get away--
give me a sandwich, you know?
And 12 years later, he
owns that company.
That's his company now.
That's the kind of
guy Neil is.
But three years ago, when my
book came out, that was edited
and produced by Todd Oldham,
he got together with me and
said, hey, you're hot
property now, man.
You've got this book.
You're in Esquire magazine.
Let's do a short film.
And that short film grew
into a feature film.
And here we are three
years later.
So that's how I met Neil.
And three years ago, I really
didn't know him still.
I thought of him as that young
kid from Oklahoma.
And our friendship grew
as this movie grew.
And the movie grew organically
out of our friendship.
I think that's one of the
powers of the movie.
There was no set agenda.
There was no M.O. There was
no outline, no script--
nothing.
We just kind of played
it by ear.
And it reflects our growing
familiarity with each other.
And his discovery of me.
Plus, like a lot of people in
their '30s, my work had a big
influence on him , through
"Pee Wee's Playhouse,"
"Beakman's World," the Smashing
Pumpkins video, et
cetera, et cetera.
So he was naturally curious
because I had this famous
stuff I did, but our
friendship was
reflected in that.
And my personal life came
out through him.
JULIE: That's awesome.
Elaine, his sister, is one
of my best friends.
So she wanted me to tell you
that she says you have
beautiful eyes.
Which you do.
RYAN GERMICK: Too beautiful
to be captured on
film by some cameras.
JULIE: Exactly.
Thank you.
WAYNE WHITE: Thank
you very much.
I don't why Elaine couldn't
tell me that in person.
JULIE: We were on the phone on
Friday and she was going to--
I was trying to talk her
into flying here.
And she was about ready to
buy her ticket and come.
WAYNE WHITE: Oh, well
that's very nice.
Thanks for relating
that information.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Come up.
CHRIS: My name's Chris.
WAYNE WHITE: Hi, Chris.
CHRIS: I'm just curious where
you think you might be headed
next in terms of creative
endeavors.
I know you're still working on
the paintings, I'm guessing.
WAYNE WHITE: Yes.
The paintings are an ongoing
project of mine that
I see no end to.
But the thing that I really am
interested in is big museum
installations, bigger
scaled things.
Did we see the--
yeah, there was a large George
Jones puppet head
laying on its side.
That's the kind of commissions
and the kind of projects I'm
continuing to work on.
I just did a big thing
down in Virginia
at the Taubman Museum.
I'm negotiating with my hometown
of Chattanooga to do
a large public work
of the words in an
actual Tennessee landscape.
So I want to scale--
and, as you saw,
the big puppet.
I'm going to be doing
some of those in
Orange County next year.
Yeah, I want to scale it up and
work on a larger scale.
And work on the museum
level kind of things.
CHRIS: Awesome.
Thank you.
WAYNE WHITE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
WAYNE WHITE: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the
Smashing Pumpkins video.
How did you decide on the
creative direction for that?
WAYNE WHITE: Well, the concept
again, just like "Pee Wee,"
was already on paper
when I came along.
They had that new album,
"Melancholy and the Infinite
Sadness." And the graphics on
the album were very Victorian
and antique.
So they wanted something
appropriately antique and 19th
century for the look.
And they hit upon the idea of
George Melies' film "A Trip to
the Moon." So that was
already on paper.
And the directors, Jonathan
Dayton and Valerie Faris.
Were friends of mine.
We'd always wanted
to work together.
And they were familiar with the
history paintings I had
been doing.
I hadn't really started the
word paintings yet.
So they knew I had a love of
19th century techniques and
that whole antiquated
kind of look.
And I love history, I'm a
big student of history.
And I loved Melies.
I already had a big picture book
of his that I pored over
constantly.
So it was a happy coincidence
that I could get
together and do that.
Again, and then I went crazy
on the concept and did a
million versions
of every scene.
So that's how that was born.
AUDIENCE: Were you helping
to actually build the
props and the sets?
WAYNE WHITE: I did build a
few of the actual props--
the moon ship that I'm holding
in the scene where I break it
and it falls apart.
I built that and a couple
of the smaller puppets.
But mainly, I did these
elaborate production paintings.
And I gave them to set builders
and they built the
sets from those.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
WAYNE WHITE: You're welcome.
We're losing them.
RYAN GERMICK: All right.
WAYNE WHITE: All right,
anyone else?
RYAN GERMICK: Going
once, going twice.
Wayne, it was awesome
to have you here.
WAYNE WHITE: It was
great to be here.
RYAN GERMICK: Come
back any time.
WAYNE WHITE: Thanks
for having me.
Thank you very much.
RYAN GERMICK: Check
out the movie.
WAYNE WHITE: Thank you.
A couple of quick things.
There's a brand new app out
right now called "Words with
Wayne." You can take
your photograph,
type in your phrase.
It'll come up as giant,
monumental block letters in
the landscape.
It's a lot of fun to use.
A lot of fun to play
around with.
Go to beautyisembarrassing.com
for a complete list of all the
theaters that "Beauty Is
Embarrassing" is going to play
at all through the fall.
And the ones that I'm going to
be making an appearance at.
Especially in Berkeley,
San Francisco, San
Jose, and Santa Cruz.
That's coming up this weekend.
Go to waynewhite.com.
There's all kinds of great
merchandising stuff there.
And there's only 200 of my
books left in the world.
So that's one of the last
places you can get them.
You can buy one there.
I'll sign it to you.
I'll do a drawing in the book.
RYAN GERMICK: There
you go, being the
hardest working guy again.
WAYNE WHITE: Yeah.
I'm going doodle-doodle-doo.
Yeah, and please check
out the movie.
I know you're all
creative people.
And it speaks to you.
It's a story about the ups
and-- a little bit of the
downs, but mostly the ups
about the creative life.
And.
I think you're really
identify with it.
I think it'll give you a shot in
the arm to watch the movie.
It's my gift to creative
people.
So enjoy.
Thank you very much
for having me.
RYAN GERMICK: Thanks.